[Music]
come on we would love to see a Taylor
Swift Katy Perry reconciliation at the
MTV VMAs but right now Katy is focused
on her hosting skills a lot of beautiful
outfits and I'm gonna keep the show
moving because we know it can be a
three-hour plus show Katy strategy humor
basically just gonna lap the whole way
through and maybe I have one joke up my
sleeve Katy who is in Pennsylvania
rehearsing for her witness tour called
in to Ryan Seacrest this morning with a
reminder to fans
I'm not Jimmy Kimmel I'm not okay Katie
in addition to hosting Katy is up for
five awards and will also perform she
claims to know nothing about Taylor
joining her on stage and producers told
us this today not so far as you know
note and that's not happening as far as
we certainly seeing all the rumors
flying around but no that's that's not
happening
we do know Katy will do a medley of
songs and the show will have an epic
start we've got a double open with
multiple performances and and of course
Katie's speech sounds like a show to
remember and the list of VMA performers
is growing Demi Lovato and dnce you will
perform live remotely from Las Vegas
[Music]
you